[Música]
aquí estamos yo me yo muy enamorados el
día de nuestra boda uniendo nuestras
vidas dos personas muy diferentes pero
que compartimos la pasión por la
aventura y la aventura fue la que nos
enseñó la importancia de nuestras
diferencias
juntos hemos escalado muchas montañas
como el pacaya en guatemala que es uno
de los 10 mil canes más activos del
planeta o el télica en nicaragua en
algunas ocasiones se me ha dicho su veto
aquí te espero como cuando fuimos a
listas igual a la vez que fuimos a la
montaña más alta de méxico en la que
ella prefirió quedarse en el refugio
mientras su gordito marido subía y
bajaba duras penas de la cima
pero al final de cuentas el goce y el
disfrute de la aventura siempre ha sido
de ambos
en kayak inflable hemos explorado más de
7.000 kilómetros conociendo lugares
fantásticos en este mapa vemos marcado
en rojo algunos de los ríos y costas que
hemos navegado y resulta que en una de
nuestras aventuras a la que llamamos
expedición uruguay ocurrió algo muy
peculiar yo algo muy peculiar algo que
nos ayudó a entender mejor nuestra
relación de pareja te cuento la historia
empieza cuando nos llevamos nuestro
kayak inflable a sudamérica como era de
esperarse pues a mí para el que me tocó
cargarlo aquí lo tengo en mi espalda en
una bolsa
estamos en el aeropuerto de buenos aires
y de ahí nos fuimos a la ciudad de
concordia de donde salvamos para
explorar 400 kilómetros del río uruguay
y 14 días después terminar en mercedes
durante la travesía fuimos visitando
cada uno de los pueblos que estaban en
la ribera del río tanto los argentinos
como los uruguayos uno de esos pueblos
fue san javier ahí conocimos a nuestros
amigos kayakistas cristian y alexander
con los que pasamos la tarde recorriendo
el pueblito es que es una antigua
colonia rusa y al día siguiente nos
acompañaron remando algunos kilómetros
mientras navegamos cristian nuestro
muestra fotos ya mí me encantó para
nosotros representa amor aventura y
relación de pareja pero esta imagen
tiene algo muy peculiar algo raro
si observamos detenidamente a la imagen
nos damos cuenta de que aparentemente no
estamos remando coordinados
inclusive pareciera como si en algún
momento en nuestros remos fueran a
chocar lo que resulta absurdo y muy raro
para kayakistas deportivos luego que es
así como se supone que se debe de remar
sobre todo en carreras de kayaks cada
remada debe ser perfectamente simétrica
e igualitaria
pero si a mí yo somos muy distintos
tenemos diferentes estaturas pesos
fuerzas y habilidades yo remo casi el
doble de velocidad por lo cual que
remueva la mitad del recorrido cuando el
deseo me apenas está entrando el agua es
por ello que no remamos iguales pero si
remamos equitativamente mi remada es más
larga más profunda más fuerte y más
rápida por lo cual no remamos
simétricamente pero si sincronizados
analizando esta imagen me percaté de que
la vida se parece más a una travesía de
exploración que una carrera de kayaks
en una travesía en la aventura se
requieren de destrezas diferentes es por
ello que tener habilidades distintas no
hace uno superior y otro inferior
simplemente nos hace distintos sin que
ello cause complejos o recriminaciones
al final de cuentas nuestra relación de
pareja es un refugio en un mundo
complicado a veces adverso no un campo
de competencia yo tengo más fuerza que
sea mi profesión me tiene más
habilidades que yo por lo que cuando
salimos de travesía
normalmente ella rema poco oa veces no
rema mi esposa es la que va tomando las
fotos controlando la vela midiendo la
velocidad la distancia que llevamos
recorrida y dado que ella es quien está
constantemente revisando el celular el
mapa y sabes dónde estamos
ella es quien determina la ruta a mí no
me hace sentir de menos el hecho que mi
esposa me diga por dónde ir o dónde
desembarcar
y así así creo que deben de ser las
relaciones humanas equitativas más no
igualitarias
hacerlo de otra forma le resta valor a
nuestras diferencias ya la diversidad
que nos enriquece el suponer nos iguales
haría la vida menos divertida nos
mediría en base a los estándares de
otros y nos impondrá cargas injustas
la verdad es que la vida no es una
competencia no se trata de ganarle a
otros
la idea es explorar vivir en armonía
disfrutar de la convivencia de nuestros
seres queridos
y realmente ser felices
es por ello que nuestras diferencias y
no sólo me refiero a las parejas
nuestras diferencias como seres humanos
son fantásticas son las que le dan
variedad a diversidad y emoción a las
relaciones humanas y gracias a ellas
encontramos en otros las habilidades y
fortalezas que nos complementan
te invito a qué valor es lo que nos hace
únicos ya quiénes son distintos a
nosotros hagamos de esta vida una
aventura no una competencia gracias
[Música]